mais
j'ai fait mes études pas loin d'ici à 2
kills
ge de kirovabad district de cuisine
j'ai commencé à faire de la lutte
pendant ma sixième année d'études
avant ça je courais je jouais au foot et
c'est tout en 9e année je commençais à
venir acquise il ourthe je faisais
l'aller retour à vélo 11 km donc je
courais 8 km et faisait 22 km à vélo
tous les jours
luz plus deux heures d'entraînement de
lutte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu à tous de man a passé par ici
non
ça
voilà comment ils sont
[Musique]
je m'entraîne sur la plage tous les
jours sauf samedi et dimanche
outreau le matin surtout en été
[Musique]
il
où
l'air est frais sur la côte est du goût
le matin quand il ne fait pas trop chaud
que l'air est frais nous profitons de la
plage de ville car chacun monde ce qu'il
sait faire au bord de la mer outre bugue
exercices matinaux shadow boxing la
lutte diverso longueur son auteur après
dur après ils luttent dans l'eau
perfectionnent leur technique de frappe
il ya beaucoup de différents exercices
et beaucoup d'air frais aux six jours
qu'ils aient tous voilà pourquoi une
fois par jour l'un des trois
entraînements se déroulent sur la plage
[Musique]
s
[Applaudissements]
il ne te laisses tranquille nulle part
tu vois qu'on nous filme et tu disais
qu'il n'y aurait pas de caméraman je
disais qu'on ne te prêtait pas attention
voilà regarde aller à trappes ce pigeon
allez allez allez doucement doucement en
toute confiance
doucement mischka vas-y michka vas-y
par l'arrière comme tu sais faire elle
ne dérange pas
tout ce que nous devons faire c'est
donner l'exemple aux jeunes mohammad
deghan ça bouge tes jambes ça te fera du
bien
chose importante il faut payer ce gars
dit roubles la quitte
le matin certains lui donnent 28
on le voyait ici il n'y a pas de signe
mais fait une bonne action
ils arrêtent les gens comme un agent de
circulation
merci je t'en prie nous allemands
tasanté frère
c'est comme ça qu'on gère la circulation
ici quelque chose et notre humour locale
j'ai participé à ma première compétition
en mai 1974
mais cette première fois j'ai terminé
deuxième à ce tournoi final j'ai perdu
en finale j'étais bon mais j'ai perdu
cette défaite a été ma première leçon
schaper on va par ici ou par là
là bas on a très bien joué ça ne te
ressemble pas comment tu as joué vingt
mille voilà comment les jeunes se
comportent
ce n'est pas très correct mais il est
peut-être plus que vous je joue ici
depuis 18 ans et l'équipe se réunit ici
depuis trente ans et wendy's rapide à
jouer sur ce terrain pendant 12 ans et
famille
[Applaudissements]
nous réunissons avec les gars il y a
cinq ou six jeunes mais la plupart sont
des vétérans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il avait un joueur de plus deux buts il
ya 2 1
il n'y a pas eu de but c'est ce que tu
as dit non je ne peux pas oublier qu
est-ce qu on peut y faire
on applaudit on y va allez allez qui
jouent mieux vous rabim aussi de
chazeaux maintenant lui bien sûr mais
quand j'étais jeune je jouais en
deuxième division
lui n'a pas joué au foot sérieusement
jouer tout simplement
il est meilleur au basket
[Applaudissements]
essayez notre fameux thé sans sucre
on regarde vers où bah oui si ses films
[Musique]
ce sont après avoir fait mon service
militaire je suis entrée à l'université
de poltava à la faculté d'économie en
comptabilité et analyse économique
largement j'étais déjà diplômée en sambo
et judo brutale dans à l'époque quand
j'étais encore étudiant j'avais le
projet d'aider les enfants des zones
rurales à faire du sport
ce conte chaud j'ai terminé l'université
et le 11 septembre 1987 j'ai lancé ma
propre école
mais
[Musique]
la pelouse
attrape le et soulève montrent leur
allez vous échauffer
c'est travail et kbc frappant à va vous
pouvez m'en temps de le dire tout le
temps surtout pendant les tournées
internationales quand on se bat avec des
étrangers je parle souvent dans ma
langue maternelle
je peux aussi parler en draghi nous en
comics facilement aussi en russie en
navarre ce n'est pas un problème
[Musique]
je
ousmane a déjà des projets où il va
lutter où il ne va pas lutter c'est
clair ousmane et un autre niveau à notre
niveau c'est bien dit
lève les bras lève les bras
oh
comme ça de bazens de base en eau sur
les pieds comme ça de bazens aux essais
de base en eau sur les pieds le pied de
vent comme ça et le deuxième lance comme
ça c'est bien un 2 celui de devant et
tout de suite le deuxième comme ça il
faut attaquer voilà très bien en 1987
j'avais déjà mon premier fils magomed
non plus tard en 1988
rabhi b né en 1991 j'ai eu ma fille donc
en tout j'ai trois enfants
nous allons là où nous devions aller
hier qu'ils illustrent yantai noyer
l'école vous avez vécu un certain temps
acquise il yourte j'ai dirigé un magasin
coopératif
j'ai été chef du magasin d'alimentation
j'ai travaillé comme économiste
comptable et directeur du groupement
agricole entraîneur chef du département
de la culture du sport du tourisme de la
politique pour la jeunesse
ensuite j'ai déménagé en 1999 à marachi
cas là où je travaille depuis
[Musique]
ok on va se garer ici pour ne gêner
personne
acx
alors tu connais ce livre oui comment tu
t'appelles magomed rassoul magomedov
azul quelqu un stylo donnez moi un stylo
magomed rastoul dois-tu ce t-shirt je
les ai achetés tu sais qui c'est oui il
est très bien tu sais qui c'est oui
abdul man ap
voilà tu dois atteindre le niveau de
cabine lui aussi il a commencé ses
études ici il était élève de cette école
mais celle de tous les combattants de
mma dont rabin jammy's savoure of rostam
kabyle of islam arad chef tous ces
combattants se sont entraînés ici
pendant 7 8 voire 10 ans pour certains
auteurs sur une vingtaine d'années nous
avons créé tout cela avec abdul manan le
club sportif bazargan sommes le premier
club que nous avons créé ensuite nous
avons lancé le pensionnat sportif
olympique ensuite l'académie de lutte où
nous nous trouvons les eagles et même à
tout cela a été créé avec abdul manable
nous avons créé ensemble inventer
ensemble
maintenant on va aller à la salle de
sport il faut toujours complimenter les
enfants quand ils travaillent leur
technique
ça s'appelle la méthode d'encouragement
on dit bien joué bravo tu es le meilleur
c'est un élément essentiel de
l'entraînement une fois par mois je
viens je ne dis à personne pourquoi
mais j'ajoute travailler plus ferme fait
des efforts bien jouer excellent etc
il faut l'envoyer au camp il doit la
compétition les élèves se motive parce
qu'ils ont envie de le faire c'est très
important de croire en eux de donner
l'exemple d' encourager mon endroit le
plus cher c'est la salle de sport le
premier à combattre ici a été fiodor ye
malienne et nico
ensuite ma here to golf ensuite rabin
pas soin de regarder la frappe 2 habite
ma modja rip off islam mcad chef qui
fait tomber claeysoone thibault chinois
graphique magomed off avec son uppercut
gauche a pris le contôle alexandre
volkov qui montre ses talents
magomed tigre magomed of shamil abdou
rakhimov chami lavrov
le succès n'arrive jamais tout seul ni à
quoi bon on y met son âme son argent sa
santé ses pensées
[Musique]
asseyez vous asseyez
nous sommes conscients que les jeunes
gens talentueux grandissent et changent
les choses je pense qu islamabad chef
peut gagner face aux autres à quoi ça
sert de m'inquiéter
il est plus jeune il en veut il devrait
prendre la place de rabin ou cuite ou en
même temps je confirme mes capacités
d'entraîneur je traduis rabbit 120
vaincu et ensuite à notre champion qui
est aussi mon élève arrive nos tout sous
jules ya aussi de jeunes gars qui sont
solides costauds les vagues à ben oumar
un move leed
ils sont nombreux je pourrais continuer
longtemps plus en plus des miens il
yad'autres russe talentueux l'anthologie
autres yann et magomed en cas la f
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir pour lui il
progresse très bien
habib magomed charipov est très bon dans
les poids lourds sergueï pavlovitch
aucun alexandre volkov outre il y a
beaucoup de jeunes talentueux
je pense qu'ils commenceront à montrer
leur niveau dans les deux trois ans à
venir
on
[Musique]